i know you're friends with jack donovan
and um you know he's a friend of mine
too and i'm i'm gonna have him on on my
podcast again soon because it's the 10th
anniversary for the way of man
um
but um
yeah like he's kind of of the opinion
just to sort of like you know leave me
alone you know let it do what it's going
to do and i'll just you know live my
life the way that i want to uh live it
but the way of men is the way of the
gang right and that's kind of the
opening to his book and i'm with you on
the whole let's draw a perimeter and
define who's on the outside and who's on
the uh sorry who's on the outside and
who's on the inside and protect those
that are on the inside nurture them and
live with them in harmony and peace and
make sure if those on the outside try to
do anything to you guys on the inside
then you're of course able to
um you know respond accordingly um but
uh
yeah it's difficult because it feels
like you're a minority you know when
you're coming from a position of look
just
you know you guys
i don't care what people do i don't care
about their
orientation whether they think they're
aziz or what pronouns they use just
don't force your crap on me right
well that but then also to go back to
what i said earlier about protecting
providing and presiding part of that and
i said it was to make sure that we do
that for people who can't do it for
themselves so when i see gender ideology
for example being shoved down the
throats of children who don't know any
better and can't defend themselves
you're damn right i'm going to say
something about it because it's not
right to mutilate physically
young boys and young girls or to
introduce them to permanent puberty and
hormone-suppressing type
chemicals
and then quite literally permanently
castrate these young children they can't
defend themselves
you know they they're physically of
course but also mentally you know we
homeschooled our kids yeah i was gonna
say like you homeschool your your kids
so how do you go about you know
defending those kids that might not be
in a position to
have an opportunity like have a dad like
you
yeah so part of it is talking about it
of course but that doesn't always go far
it never goes far enough just talking
about it but it's also rallying other
men
to do the same for their families that's
why i've always been an outspoken
proponent not always more recently
proponent of homeschooling and then i
also encourage men to get involved in
their communities so that means coaching
your
sons and daughters baseball teams and
sports teams it means going to student
council or excuse me um
school board meetings getting involved
in pta getting involved in local
politics so that we can do what we need
to do to protect our youth from these
horrible horrible and destructive
ideologies that are being presented with
these days
speaking of ideologies what do you think
of the uh mgtow movement the men going
their own way thing
this has always been so i get this
question
quite often um
i think there's some validity to what
they're sharing uh i think that if there
wasn't it would be repulsive
so you you have to dabble some truth
into it
but to me it seems like whether it's the
mgtow or the or or or the red pill
movement seems to be coming an
increasingly extreme version
of confident
courageous
capable men and is in a way turning into
the
extreme feminist version for men
and i have a problem with that because
you take young men
who are
impressionable who are confused who
don't have male influences in their
lives and you teach them that you're
gonna you're gonna make them a badass by
going their own way by by not being
involved with women by painting
everything else is the enemy and i think
that leads to a life of
contention and animosity and hostility
and anger definitely not fulfillment
what's the difference between mgtow and
the red pill movement as you see it
um i
i don't know i can't really answer that
maybe i'm unfairly lumping those two
into the same category um and maybe you
can enlighten me on that a little bit
i've just seen so much from it that i
tend to just distance myself from
from that arena because i don't want to
go there i really want to serve men in
constructive ways and i don't see some
of these movements going that way yeah
so um to kind of add some context to
that so
i was i was involved in what was called
the manosphere i've called it the mantle
swamp now
um for the last couple years because
that's really what it looks like to me
um and the guys that are mgtow are
definitely red-pilled
but the guys that are red-pilled aren't
necessarily going their own way right
like there's a lot of guys that are red
pill that understand women that
understand you know what drives
attraction what drives you know women
away um how to manage stuff over a long
term basis
i think overall like being red pilled
and to me like i call it the you know
like unplugging like i called my book
the unplugged alpha i know you've
probably seen it because you know we
follow each other on um sure yeah
instagram but my book was basically
built around the notion that
you definitely want to unplug and red
pill yourself and here's some ways that
you can apply that to your life so that
you can have better experiences in life
and with women
i'm not opposed to dealing with women
i'm in a long-term relationship have
been for a while now um i have a chapter
in my book actually about mgtow i think
you'd like it because it kind of hits on
some of the stuff that you're getting at
but it goes a lot deeper down the rabbit
hole yeah i'd love to check it out yeah
it's an interesting um
like
segment of of like men's spaces because
you see like
you know the trad con space the mgtow
guys the black pill guys the different
color like there's all these different
colors of pills now you know there's
white purple red blue it's like nobody
can make up their lgbtqtt of
awakening pills yeah it's all of a
sudden turning into the alphabet soup of
you know
like the alphabet crowd is now turning
into different colored pills right and
everybody wants to like hold theirs you
know the highest like this is the best
right if you don't subscribe to mine
then i'm going to hate you sort of thing
so or or if you don't subscribe to mine
then i'm a victim of you which is even
worse yeah yeah it's uh i guess if
according to what you're saying you know
if you're saying it that way
i would consider myself red pill in a
way in that i i recognize it for what it
is i'm not gonna
make myself subservient to women or
think that i'm inferior but i'm also not
going to take it to the extreme and
think that they don't add an amazing
dynamic to life that is so valued in a
thriving society you know
so
i do get very skeptical when we start
placing
uh these types of terms around it like
manosphere which i don't like i like
mana swamp uh
red pill mgtow
uh
it concerns me because
even trad con then it becomes tribal and
the
but aren't men tribal though
yes by the way of men is the way of the
gang right
it's true but if we can't expose
ourselves to new information because
we're so extremely tribal that anything
from the outside isn't a threat to us
here's an example is that
in modern culture especially on social
media like people won't even have
conversations i had phil robertson on
the podcast he's he's very spiritual um
half of our conversation was him going
through passages from the bible which
doesn't bother me that's fine if that's
his context and his framework in which
he views life which mine is somewhat
overlapped not to the level his is
that's fine but i had a guy say well you
know i'd be very careful of aligning
yourself with him a line because i had
him on the podcast
yeah because i had a conversation with a
man who's is saying something
interesting yeah they don't have to
agree with everything he says yeah i get
to see what's going to do like i'll talk
to somebody that that like one
subscriber doesn't like and he's like
unsubscribe it's like dude i don't care
like you really have to write that
leap just go yeah exactly so i think i
think it becomes a problem when we cling
so hard to our ideologies whatever side
of the aisle or spectrum they're on that
we aren't willing to at least consider
that maybe there's another way of
looking at it and that's what i mean
when i say becoming tribal yeah hey guys
i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you